these are the police pigeons and they
have a storied history in India
dating back to the British colonial era
when they used to send messages between
distant police stations despite massive
leaps in communication technology please
hear an odisha State have been keeping
the tradition alive we have it since
1946 and this service was basically used
for communicating from one station to
another station
now we have kept it as a heritage
training begins early for new recruits
rookies enter the service as young as
six weeks old
they're dropped further and further away
from the coop and rely on instinct to
get back home
before long they can carry messages
hundreds of kilometers
and there are times when the police rely
on their avian allies
during the odisha cyclone in 1999
conventional communication was disrupted
pigeons proved one of the only reliable
ways for police to keep in contact
urisa is the only place where officially
you know there are private pigeon you
know Keepers who do it officially under
government sanction with the police
we have an organization where the
pigeons are used kept and that makes it
very unique
these days they mainly see action at
National festivals Taking Flight as a
symbol of peace
but please hear say that the pigeons are
ready whenever Judy calls
Vincent Monaghan Al Jazeera